what's up guys I'm Sabrina carpenter I'm
here at BuzzFeed and I'm here to answer
some of your questions oh my goodness
are you bringing in a lot of puppies
right now hi kids
hey this is amazed how many are there oh
my goodness let's begin you gonna grab
some for me
eat them alrighty one was a time that
you were starstruck when I met
lin-manuel Miranda I don't know why I
felt unworthy I couldn't speak when I
met him for some reason and I was so
uncool about it what's your dream acting
role I would probably be to star in a
movie with a lot of dogs so that way I
could do this on set every day
also a dream role that I've always
wanted I've always wanted to do a
musical I've always wanted to collide
those tools that I have it I'd like to
do an action film that would be really
cool is yours on Paris about a real
relationship yes there's so many times
in my life where we're focused on
something else that we're missing what's
right in front of us but right now is
not one of those times I'm very focused
on what's in front of me and not worried
about owning anything else in the future
and so yeah these are that question
you're eating my heel that's cool okay
we're gonna go to the next one what was
your reaction when you were chosen to be
part of the hate you give had you
already read the book I had already read
the book and I was very very excited
because I knew that it was going to be
an incredibly important movie and now
that I have been a part of it and I've
seen the movie multiple times it is one
of the most emotional experiences and
rollercoasters I think I've ever been
through in my life these are very deep
philosophical questions to be in a room
surrounded by puppies I'm I'm not very
focused right now this is a good one do
you prefer cheese or chocolate chocolate
right once I did an interview in a ball
pit but I'd like to say I have a lot
more going on here I think I like dogs
better than balls I was quite a sound
bite wasn't it yes you are stuck on a
desert island and can only pick one of
your co-stars to be with you who do you
pick ooh I feel like my friend and
co-star danielle fishel would be very
good to have on island with me because
she's very smart I feel like we would
get out of the island if I was with
Danielle you know Danielle has a dog
named brunch I could introduce you guys
if you would like what would 19-year old
Sabrina say to 12 year old Sabrina be a
little more selective about what you
post on the Internet you're not gonna
like it all later you're not gonna like
most of it later if you start in a
rom-com who would you want to play your
co-star I would want you to be my
co-star can you be my co-star in a
rom-com I really do celebrity crushes I
feel like I was just talking the other
day though about how I once went up to
Zac Efron when I saw him on the beach
and I was 11 and I told him about I
liked his work and he wasn't wearing a
shirt and that's how composed I was as
an 11 year old I said I'm a big fan of
your work and he was so nice to me but I
just like remember being that nerd at 11
years old if you could sing her act with
any celebrity pastor present who would
it be and why I would want to sing with
Paul McCartney and I would want to add
Judy Garland if I were to name them you
would be Budweiser just name them after
but you would be Dos Equis you would be
Coors Light you would be Diet Coke and
then you would be Chandler Bing
I'm not a Monica though I'm I think I'm
more of a Rachel or Phoebe would be your
dream collaboration yes
just eat it I already know the question
now here's the thing is this is such a
hard question because I have so many I
don't feel like I could choose one but I
do I really do love I'm a big fan of our
Campton I'm a big big fan of Rihanna my
fans know that and I love Adele I really
love Adele where did the name singular
come from listen up kids so I named my
new album singular because I felt like
after I had kind of tied up the album
writing classes I'd gone back and
listened you can be free for a minute
you've been with me the whole time or no
come back okay after I kind of tied up
the album writing process I'd gone back
and listened to a lot of my favorite
songs and realized that this overall
theme for the album was this unspoken
confidence I was talking to someone who
had listened to the album and one of the
words that they used to describe it was
singular and it stuck in that moment I
didn't look back and I'm very happy I
didn't I haven't wanted to change it
even though I've had it for a while I
just felt like the right the right thing
you've now worked with two of the
Riverdale stars KJ and Casey cot are you
a fan of the show I'm a fan of both of
them and I have I watched the whole
first season I I'm very bad at finishing
shows so I'm still in the second season
but they're so talented
tell us what singular means to you in
three words
I'd say my next chapter say it's a part
of my life that I will never ever forget
and I'm creating new memories with it
every day starting right now I know that
all I'll look back and I'll think so
many things about this album and where I
was at this point in my life but I
definitely will never forget it and
it'll always be that thing that takes me
to where I'm going next empty jar and
the puppy's still on my lap that means
I'm taking it home I love you Chandler
being yo y'all really know how to do it
that's all I'm gonna say y'all really
just know how to make someone's day I
top it out today I don't care I got
puppies I got so many dogs around me you
see this smile I never smile like this
ever thank you guys so much it's been so
much fun make sure to check out my new
album singular act one and I can't wait
to be back soon and my standards are
pretty high now all these puppies are up
for adoption at North Shore Animal
League America but they say woof look
they're just bite me
[Music]